okay these are the questions from the
Internet's Ben Williams 869 says Zak
would you be funny without your beard
like Samson you know we get your power
from a little it's true but when I
shaved my beard I look like a fat Jodie
Foster just making a joke is there any
way to neutralize the influence of the
Iowa caucus on presidential primaries Oh
what is a better alternative you know
what there should yeah that would be
great
the reason were that he looks like a fat
Jodie Foster from all the corn that they
pump into our food to get Iowa okay all
Iowa's fault that's why they that's why
there's corn everywhere you kidding me
well that is true you're right winner as
I would picked a winner
in the last few presidential elections
they're always picking the crazy they
just picked the guy that made bread we
subsidize corn yeah they never actually
picked the butter so it becomes
president but especially on the
Republican side because it's a very you
know AB angelical group that goes to the
caucuses and it doesn't you know I've
said this before I used to go to Iowa a
lot it does not represent Iowa I was not
a hick state it's one of our richest
states as a matter of fact can I just
say something I don't eat a lot of corn
okay actually you know what you may not
know you eat a lot of corn but I bet you
you do and you don't even know it I know
you eat a food from the from the
supermarket in America I hunt all corns
at my bare hands no you don't do you
think about corn when you masturbate in
China oh here's a question about China
[Laughter]
four-year-old and in China's China with
its rapid economic growth and danger of
succumbing to the same financial
chicanery as we did I doubt it because
right they do not have to answer to a
Congress have a soda we have we we they
have a state-run bank that decides how
much money they have and what they're
going to do with it we have a state
subsidized oligarchy where we give the
bank's money and then they take the
money right different model right and
tiger mom you would not want to live in
China no no I wouldn't want to live I
mean you know I sometimes I say things
about China and people say well why
don't you go to move to China I
recognize that I don't want to live in
China and their system is worse than our
system I also recognize that you know
they do get things done I'm not saying
we should have a dictatorship but Obama
is begging just you know for money to
build like eight billion dollars of
high-speed rail China is building I
think 300 billion dollars of high-speed
rail and they and they turned on like
for a long time that the argument was
well we might as well not go green
because China is polluting and they were
and China turned on a dime and green GDP
right evaluates based on green and yet I
don't wanna be a party pooper but right
now China is throwing up a lot of houses
health prices are rising quite fast and
there is some hint of some of the
housing bubble mania that we saw in
America right so it's not all rosy in
China well have you do you travel there
sometimes last two weeks of June oh yeah
yeah I've been a couple of times but not
in the last five years
that's the corn there
a lot of Chinese food is cooked with
corn oil I was I was at last year and
you go around some of these new cities
and you see this enormous number of
tower blocks are throwing up everywhere
and people aren't actually even living
in them yet and you got to start asking
questions about any economy that grows
out fast
is it actually sustainable we've got
like 20 cities that are like 5 million
people that we've never even heard of
right Iowa right I mean Shanghai is like
well you'd fit 10 New York's in a
Shanghai right that's huge it's too big
right but I bet you can find any kind of
food at 4:00 in the morning there except
Chinese well they just call it food
[Laughter]
it's also a great Chinatown there I'm
with corn syrup - yeah
Michelle Obama had a real career before
her husband ran for president what would
the reaction have been if she decided to
keep her day job skipping all the trips
appearances PSAs etc well I never
thought of that I mean she did have a
real job she worked in a hospital right
wasn't she of a high level administrator
she made more than Obama did REM know I
mean look this is what we we demand this
of our of our first lady's but that said
I think that Michelle Obama is
completely redefining the the role I
mean she is she is I think probably you
know one of the strongest first ladies
of the last hundred years I mean even
and and what what I think what I mean
when I
say that is obviously and also one of
the hottest and very hot yes I mean what
I mean is that Hillary Clinton
understood this this position as a
stepping stone for her for her political
career and that's not what I mean we're
not gonna see my Secretary of State
Michelle Obama in ten years from now she
actually does believe that this is a
role that provides her with a platform
to do the kinds of things that she would
that's an interesting question what
would have happened if Michelle Obama
said I'm keeping my job great the
president congratulations I'm sorry for
you I'm keeping my job well in the UK in
fact semantic camera and the wife of
David Cameron Prime Minister has done
that to a degree and actually people
have been quite accepting and didn't
Cherie Blair keep her job she was a
lawyer right yes she did I mean you
think would help your job if your
husband was the president get better
meetings let's say unique you know
conflicts of interest that have to be
managed very carefully but I think in
the modern age on the one hand there's a
great role for wives to play in terms of
supporting public service but at the
same time I think many people want to
see that the wives actually are
independent beings are not simply coming
along purely in a secondary role well
some people want to see that some people
all right gotta go thank you folks we'll
take a break for a week we'll be back